[Music]
a record number of young people in China
graduated from college this year but
instead of celebrating
some are marking the Milestone on social
media by lying down flat on the ground
in their graduation gowns looking
dejected and exhausted
after studying for years they're
frustrated with the struggle to find
decent work as China's youth
unemployment rate hits historic highs so
for some the better option for now is to
stay at home as so-called full-time
children if you have a lot of idle young
people who are not employed it adds
pressure on social stability which is
what the government really is concerned
about here's why millions of Chinese
graduates are out of work
the term full-time children has gone
viral on Chinese social media videos
show young people spending time with
their parents cooking and cleaning in
exchange for a salary
they are choosing to stay at home
full-time they are counting on their
parents to continue support them
financially this is what many people are
referring to as the lie flat phenomenon
in China lying flat essentially means to
resist the intense social pressure to
study hard and work even harder
a record 11.6 million young Chinese
graduated from college this year almost
12 times more than 20 years ago students
they have much higher expectation for
their job income their job stability and
what they can derive by doing work but
the graduates soon found that they're
competing with thousands of others for
only a handful of jobs that match their
skills and expectations Urban Youth
unemployments hit a records 21.3 percent
in June joblessness in China increased
dramatically in recent years while other
countries such as the US saw a spike in
youth unemployments during the pandemic
that rapidly fell as restrictions were
eased China maintained covert controls
for longer than most countries keeping
its borders closed from 2020 to early
2023 major cities went through extended
lockdowns that disrupted production as
the economy slowed so too did hiring
China's youth unemployment race Rose for
six consecutive months this year then in
August the government abruptly announced
that it would stop reporting that data
citing plans to revisit the methodology
analysts say the suspension fits a
worrying pattern of haziness around the
true state of China's economy
to address the youth unemployment
problem local governments ordered
state-owned companies to hire more
graduates
they're also pushing young people to
take up blue collared work but that's
unappealing for a lot of college
graduates a survey from online
recruitment platform Xiaoping found that
a quarter of this year's graduates want
to work on the technology sector despite
the fact that some of China's biggest
Tech firms had massive layoffs following
a regulatory Crackdown on the industry
so our last confidence revive in those
sectors young college graduates will
likely continue to struggle in terms of
what kind of work they're looking for to
do
down the line having millions of young
people out of work will have serious
Ripple effects for China's Society hi
joblessly among young people also
exacerbate many other structural
challenges that China already is dealing
with for example without stable jobs
many people are putting off getting
married they don't want to have kids and
all these will make China's demographic
situation even worse some a warning of a
Lost Generation it's adding to a long
list of challenges for Beijing to boost
growth and attract foreign investors as
well second largest economy tries to
rebuild from the pandemic